yeah
yeah what do you think do you think
women like red flags
okay i mean i can attest to the fact
that i've seen red flags before and been
like
i don't know what that is
is that red now i think it's white i
think is it green i think it's green
yeah maybe i'm just colorblind you know
why that is i feel like for sure but i
would say that like
because i think sometimes you get
wrapped up in someone right sometimes
you're like no you see the red flag
you're like nah no i get i could tell
you this i could tell you the scientific
reason behind it it's because the same
traits that make like the person the
villain are the same that make him the
like the hero yeah so it's like like a
guy that um
like is abusive let's just say it's the
same guy that can protect you so it's
like the same traits like a guy that's
super disagreeable like they tend to
make more money but they also tend to be
[ __ ] yeah so it's like it's like uh
i forgot what they call them they call
like the dark triad traits
what if you can't dress i kind of like a
my man a little cheap
[Music]
i do you are a dime a dozen look at it
look at it because i really don't
understand it's because i'm cheap like
when it comes to like because i just
don't understand like why you be
spending all this money on like clothes
like yeah i don't get it interesting
yeah because i would say that style
doesn't like i wouldn't look at you and
go
it's not real gucci
i mean i'd morby like it's fake gucci
i know a lot of girls that care about
how how a guy dresses i would say i'm
more than expected
it's just more how you put it together
yeah yeah yeah
so i i like i like a guy with style and
and this is not even it doesn't have to
be my style i like someone who's gone
i've put thought into my outfit because
i put thought into what i wear and i
think it's nice if someone makes an
effort even if it's like you know like
i'm not normally saying you would go for
like the turtleneck tailored wool coat
look but if i see someone repping that
i'm like yeah that's hot
a suit can do wonders for a guy like
what is it
like a suit is the equivalent of like
i don't know like a sexy like a sexy red
dress on a girl or like i don't know but
yeah for sure like i swear a suit brings
up a guy like at least a point yeah at
least i think part of it as well is
because the tailored cut of the suit is
like if you've got like a bit of a belly
or whatever like it goes over that
because especially a really nice
tailored suit like the structuring of
that i started off in film i started off
doing costuming dogs and styling jobs
and things so it's like oh man like if
someone is styled well i'm like sir you
thought about your outfit today and i
appreciate that but i would but but
going back to the point of red flags um
crocs are a red flag no um
no if uh if if uh
i think for sure there's been points
when i've gone to the gym i was wearing
like green crocs
were you i didn't even notice
no
i don't really pay attention to that
stuff
you're fine
i think i think for sure been in
situations before when i've seen
something that's problematic and i think
sometimes you either downplay it because
you're like
maybe i'm overreacting
which is for sure a thing because you
kind of almost gaslight yourself and i
think that's definitely a thing i think
that's the thing as well for for women i
don't know if that's so much thing for
men but for women definitely kind of
going i just am i am am i overthinking
this am i thinking about too much am i
being a bit weird
but i think in general the the trend
that i've had relationship to
relationship is that i go okay
i identified that red flag and now when
i see that in potential partners
now i go haha yeah i've seen that red
flag before don't want that again like
and there's different things and it's to
varying degrees sometimes reflects come
out of nowhere but i think um i think
sometimes yeah i think and and i think
that's another thing is as you go
through more and more relationships and
as you get older and more mature i think
you get better at seeing them
identifying them and they're not falling
again guys felons have 30 percent more
kids than non-felons
case closed on women's picking skills
no surprise i literally tell my dad i'm
like dad you can literally pick my
husband i swear to god like
i know i swear i
i've told my dad this so many times but
he wants nothing to do with that he's
like because if it goes wrong you'll
blame me
i was thinking about this the other day
because i was thinking
who would who would my parents pick for
me and i was trying to think would they
pick someone good or would they be
picking one no they they they'd pick a
square but that's who like you should
pick yeah
good square would they pick a square
that i'd be like i can respect this
because i don't mind a square you know
right i'm not out here trying to
i literally told my dad i was like dad i
swear to god i want to get married and
you can't you can
go hat but he said no well he would have
picked for you guys like your parents
would pick feet up my dad well no my dad
he'd have to understand he like hates
people for one
and like for two he just like he's i
have nine siblings there's ten of us so
he's just like like you're 25 leave me
alone yeah
and third of all he doesn't he's like no
you make your own choices and deal with
the decisions like don't put this on me
yeah
because the thing is like i know
definitely you two either your mama or
grandma or uncles that are if you've
come back to nigeria gonna i got a
wife's land up for you 100
i wish i wish so my aunt is like that my
i live with my aunt my aunt is so like
that she's literally like yeah yeah yeah
like any any any any guy or girl who
walks through the door she's like she is
trying she's trying to set me up for
life literally if she was here right now
she'd be eyeing each three of you up
four of you even if you were that way
inclined but like she would fully be
like trying to work out like who's the
best fit for me she'd probably end up
being like they're all lovely marry all
of them yeah they could take chris chris
is six six right now to be fair
[Music]
my dad is five foot seven so i feel like
i need some of your six foot nine jeans
like in my family for like for the
survivor shoot your shot shoot your shot
emily
is this going to be a thing
you guys want to go on a date you guys
it could be like 11.
in it
finding love on the pre-game
no
why
it's just like what
it comes from a good place in it but
it's just say it with your chest
[Music]
i don't want no disclaimers
you don't take into consideration
are they fat
yes or no
is it's listen
i don't feel like my mom looks at me and
thinks like she doesn't judge for me
just for herself
and i feel like the way that she she
looks at like
she's a good person so therefore
that's good for you
but like you don't think they're high
[Music]
it's just not
they're not taking a